If we show you a random shape, your eyes
will send the information to your brain
which will then decide what to
do with it - perhaps not much.
If we show you another shape, your
senses will again send it to your brain,
but now it might be able to find some related
information that was stored in your memory.
What’s going on here?
You may have forgotten, but when you
were young, you knew nothing. The
first time you saw a particular shape, it was
meaningless. Over time and in search for order,
you started to recognize patterns. One day
someone gave that particular thing meaning,
your mind labeled it as important and
decided to store it for future use.
The next time you see that thing,
you recognize it and link it to
a previous experience. The more often
you make such meaningful experiences,
the more data will be stored in your memory
and your understanding of that matter grows.
And one day, when you see that particular
shape you’ll say “it’s an ape!”,
and if you give your mind some
time to look up all those memories,
it might come up with lots of things you
can relate to this one piece of digital ink.
So how does your memory work?
The multi-store model asserts that
the human brain has three processors.
A sensory register, where new information enters.
a short term memory, which
quickly assesses the input, and
a long-term store, where it can
potentially be held forever.
We need attention to get things to the
short-term memory, rehearsal to hold it
there for longer and transfer for sending it
to long term storage — and bringing it back.
Let’s now try to understand
how everything interacts.
Our life is a continuous stream of stimuli
that we perceive in different ways.
There are our senses such as vision, touch,
smell, hearing and taste. There are internal
states such as stress, sleepiness, or hunger.
And there are emotions, wants and intentions.
All of them are part of the sensory input
that our brain has to process all the time.
The sensory register can perceive any such new
stimuli. They are then filtered by attention
processes and decomposed into manageable chunks.
These chunks of information are then sent further.
The short-term memory holds the new info for a
moment. Then it will either forget it, transfer
it to the long term memory, or instantly
use it by bringing it to our attention.
Also known as working memory, our
attention can hold about 7 bits of
information for a few seconds to complete a task.
If we pay attention, our brain can
send fresh memories to the long-term
store. This happens especially well
when we rest. During sleep we tend
to consolidate important things and
discard others — which we then forget.
The Long-term memory is a vast library of
stories, experiences, facts and concepts,
some of which we can recall for life, and
others we are unable to remember the next day.
Inside this long-term store are
again different types of memories.
There are episodic memories which are chunks of
detailed information with a high emotional value.
Such as all your stories, some of which you might
be able to recall in great detail. Like the first
day of school or your first kiss. Maybe you can
even recall some specific thoughts from that day.
There are semantic memories, things
like facts or general knowledge.
Repeated episodic memories, like the
way to school, can also, over time,
turn into semantic information. You can think
of such memories as a large network of ideas:
If you see a particular shape, you may
think: gorilla - ape - human - intelligence.
Episodic and semantic memories are
known as explicit memories. They are
conscious recollections. They are all the
information and experiences we know we hold.
There are also implicit memories, skills
and things you are not aware of. The
process of walking relies on muscle memory.
You’ve learned it by trying and failing,
and today you have no idea how you actually do
it. Implicit memories are also at work when we
unconsciously react to a stimulus
— a process known as conditioning.
To make things more complicated, our memories
often change. Sometimes we forget parts,
sometimes we add new details to old
memories in response to how we feel
right now. When we think of a holiday we
took with someone we don't like anymore,
a trip that was actually nice, might
be remembered as unpleasant today.
So next time you see this or that shape,
you might want to pause and pay tribute
to the fact that there are more connections
in your brain than stars in the universe,
here to help you organize inputs, thoughts
and memories to get you through life.
Now, the best thing about memories is
still creating them! Trying new things,
failing and then trying them again
is one good way to do just that!
If you like how we explain complicated
ideas in simple cartoon animation,
you can support us. Go to
patreon.com/sprouts. Just visit us,
learn how it works, and what’s in it
for you. We hope to see you there!
And if you are a lifelong learner, a parent or
an educator, check our website sproutsschools.com
There you’ll find this and other video lessons,
additional resources, and classroom activities.